everybody welcome to live coding with
Jesse today we're gonna continue on with
what we're doing
but I had an idea this morning about how
to cut down on the number of components
that we're using so I'm gonna try to
implement that idea I'm not sure I don't
know I'm not sure if it'll work I
haven't tried anything with it I just
was getting ready for work this morning
and it just came to me so we'll see
let's see if it works let's see oh come
on the wrong projects I wonder why I
couldn't I see what we were working on
so I just been migrating a lot of data
still not through yet and so this is
what we've been doing every time we
bring in fewer pages or pages so we keep
making a new page for every different
type of content but it occurred to me
that a lot of these are exactly the same
we just have a different different
content types we're just grabbing
different content with graph QL so we
have all these pages that are basically
the same with the exception of the name
and then we also have all these queries
that are exactly the same except for the
name so why not just have one page
component that accepts not only the the
ID to get you know the specific type of
content that we want but it will also
accept from the router the the content
type ok so then we can pass into the
query
so let me alright so right here we're
passing in the ID wow that's way too
small let me make it big so we're
passing in the ID here and then if we go
to an actual component we can see it's
pulling the ID here and then that's
getting passed to our query and then in
our query we're using that here for name
so what if we not only passed in the
name but we also passed in this so then
we'd be able to use the same query for a
variety of pages and we'd be able to use
the same component for a variety of
pages and I think this will work as I've
been looking through the content on the
site you know even more there's gonna be
a lot of content that just has the same
basic structure I think this works well
it'll enable us to work faster and be
less cluttered and then it still leaves
open the possibility of customizing the
different parts of the site later on
because it wouldn't be that big of a
deal to just change you know where a
certain route goes so instead of using
our default component we can make
another component later or customize the
default so we'll have different options
so anyway let me know if that makes
sense if there's any objections to that
otherwise that's what we're gonna try to
do first and then we'll leave everything
that we've done already we'll just leave
it no sense in redoing it right now but
then as we bring in new content types
we'll just route them through that
default query and that default page
component
okay and I do need to keep this stream
you know somewhat short so we'll see
depending on how many questions are in
the live chat I may cut the the coding
part short so I have to pick up my kids
from school so I got to make sure I get
the stream ended and finished anything I
need to finish before I leave today
alright so I guess the best thing to do
would just be to copy one of these pages
so let's copy that and make a new page
and actually we already have page j/s
let's just make page is what we use here
so page works and do we have the postage
a s might be what went with page j s so
we might just change that name to page
dodged ass cuz i don't think we're using
that for anything else right now but
first things first let's get this set up
so we're gonna import i guess we'll call
this page query page query and we'll
call this page even though it doesn't
exist yet and then down here we're going
to want to do page query and then for
our options
we're gonna want to pass in let's see ID
can we do it too like this can we no ID
and type okay there was I so we'll have
name ID and then let's go with type type
all right let's see we do want to change
the name of this to page oh I forgot
about this part okay so we do want to
make sure that we use loonies type let's
see if we can we put bring in - all
right and then let's use type here I
think that'll work
oh you know maybe we need
today shoot how am I gonna get it within
here I needed to be this right are we
getting this props data I don't want
that I want
I guess this props tight okay sorry I'm
not doing a good job of explaining
what's going on here so for those of you
who aren't great with with react here's
here's who we're doing so when we pull
things in here with next J s which is
what we use to build this react up when
you return these they become available
as as props right the function is get
initial props so then down here where
I'm going to grab the data eventually
the data is going to be available in
props so we have this props and we made
this cost data right so we don't have to
type this props all the time so that's
what we're starting with data but then
for the type since the types now going
to be variable we're gonna grab this
props types which is going to pull in
whatever type we pass in from our server
gas file
we're also passing that same thing down
to here to the query so it it should
hopefully it'll make sense once we get
it worth if we get it working so it may
not it may not work this was just the
idea I had earlier I've never never
tried it so maybe that's better let me
try see if it works first and then we
can go back and explain it no sense
trying to explain something that doesn't
really work anyway all right
let me make the capital H all right
that's I think that's what we need from
now so let's go in here to our queries
let's grab this but then I want to go to
our post query alright great so this is
the sample one faculty departments did
we take this you know what I'm not a
hundred percent sure that this isn't in
you somewhere so I'm not gonna change
this let's make a new query called page
and now let's paste this in and so here
we have this variable name but now we're
also going to have the variable type mmm
hopefully this this works out it says
you might inquire - been defiled ok and
let's change this to page query
page query
oh shoot alright so we word in a query
we're defining name string and let's say
type string all right I'm not sure that
seems like that's that had to happen but
I'm not entirely sure let me check the
live chat to see make a function let's
see oh ok harsh it's saying that we I
can't use this like that so I'm let me
see the timestamp on that okay so that
was just a minute ago so I'm assuming
that I can't do this what I'm trying to
do is that what you're saying
all right so I'm waiting to hear that
Harsha says make a function I'm not I'm
on time percent sure what what would
your you're talking about harsh it so
I'm sure you know what you're talking
about but I don't know so I'm just gonna
keep I need to make a route anyway so
while I'm waiting on hard [ __ ] to
explain more I will go to the server
file and let me get rid of some of these
because we certainly don't need all of
these all right I should send me a link
to jsfiddle let's check it out
oops
okay let's see I'm gonna copy and paste
what Harshit has in here so we all can
see and compare all right so let's check
it out all right so we could see the
making it a function so we have
associate query name we're pulling in
where name is name
all right let me see
to
I should say in return alright alright
I'm a little bit confused so why are
these why is this name name here this
one named name could I do this variables
are part of graph chaos in size the
dollar sign yeah so with the dollar sign
that that's why I was thinking that I
had to make a dollar sign variable here
if I wanted to use it in here but what
I'm wondering about is like can I rename
this name here in this name here to type
okay I just don't want it to be too
confusing with lots of different
variables name name or dollar sign name
okay and we can change just the page
query okay cool let's get rid of this
all right so now essentially we kind of
have this function wrapper around here
and then we're passing in the type do I
need to let's see okay good point harsh
it okay so harsh it's explaining that
since this these back ticks make it a
template literal that's why we can pass
this variable in like this
okay now Harsha do we need to change
anything in terms of how we're bringing
the variable for name in or we or should
we be good with that okay
I still say that let's go back to our
page Jas and graph queue a page query so
should we then do put the ID in like
like here or will it still work to add
our options in here so basically what
I'm saying is you know should we put in
type here
this probe side
okay I should say no change
okay all right that's what I thought so
we can get rid of this and this okay
all right so we have this we have this
we need a route now leave that and don't
say all right so far out gonna be oh
yeah we could use we can use any of our
outs so let me just grab something we've
already made so we can copy it and what
did I pull over about yeah I think I
pulled over some of the about pages
yesterday so let's do that cuz we
haven't made I mean let me double check
in my wordpress installation to make
sure that we do have content for those
okay I do have those pages
okay in about five minutes I'm gonna
take a break and go back to the live
chat answer some questions all right so
we're gonna have a rout like this it's
gonna be about and then an ID and then
we're going to send then send it to the
page component and with ID we're also
gonna send a type and the type will be
about page okay and let's restart the
server all right let me give you the end
Rock link as well so I didn't give that
out yet yeah I think it's still on from
yesterday it is this should still work
from yesterday so I'm gonna paste the
same link in if it's not working I'll
restart it but if you click the link I
just paste it into the live chat you
should be able to see the website now
alright cool looks like it's working and
I'm gonna restart the server here so it
may not work for a few seconds
okay let's feel about and then I need to
find content where's my page adding some
my other screen
let's see
this should be one let's see how are you
props have undefined alright let's let's
verify that this is the slug ya our
mission should be one it's gonna be
property props oh okay
for a page which is 46 okay so I can't
do this props type here hmm
type is not defined well let's see if
it'll pass type is not the fine okay all
right so how do we get to type in here
let's make sure that whoops let me bring
the lad chat up
okay rook says try component name prop
site okay we try that I don't know if
that'll work or not but that's worth a
shot
all right yeah it's not working either
man I I remember having it might have
been the same problem and I can't
remember what I did about it and I hate
when that happens
okay
Harshit says use recompose i don't know
what recomposes
so I'm assuming recompose is a react
Apollo thing
all right so I just looked up recompose
okay I guess I just read an article on
recomposed so it wasn't really
documentation
all right cool iPhone the github of it
now
it looks like it can do a lot of stuff
okay
alright let me bring in how about this
yeah it's time let me take five minute
break go to the lab chat answer some
questions and then when we come back
we'll bring in recompose and try to get
access to the props down here to test
this out actually we can test this up
right now let's test that page it was
about page
sorry property edges is undefined huh
this is it not passing it in maybe it's
not passing things in like I want type
of out page hmm
hmm
we might have other issues as well all
right well let's let me go to the live
chat I'm gonna think about five minutes
go through the chat if you have any
questions please put them in the live
chat and I'll get through as many as I
can Dacron said I started work at 5:00
a.m. that's pretty early to start
working Nicky says there are three hard
things in programming naming things and
off-by-one errors I like that one let's
see
I'm third this says it's like the there
are two things you should know about
INFJs one they never tell you everything
I enough dad that's like from the
myers-briggs personality test right I
can't remember what all the letters
stand for I don't even remember what I
am
but logic said can you please arrange
your videos and properly it would be
really helpful yeah I I do plan on
arranging the videos I know I've been
saying that for a long time it's just
you know there's a whole list of things
that I want to do and arranging the
videos just has never made it like to
the top of that list but I would like to
arrange them so far I've had two
different suggestions one is arrange
them by project which would be pretty
easy to do the other one is to arrange
them by topic so that no matter what
project it is you could see every video
I've ever done on let's say graph QL or
routing or something you know which
would be a lot harder because some
videos I do a variety of things and so I
I don't know I mean it would be hard to
go back and watch every video to see
what I've done cuz I I don't always
title them or give them a description
with everything that I'm doing so I
don't know I don't know if I'll be able
to get them arranged by topic but I can
definitely arrange them at least by
projects
ravi rajesh says this was cool but i
have no idea what is happening feel free
to ask as many questions as you want
some of the shows are a little bit
easier to understand depending on what
we're working on Richard says I knew
what's he working on I mean Michael also
says I'm always late so I've no idea
what's going on right now right now
we're trying to make a component a graph
QL query in a graph he'll query that
could we can pass in the the type of
content that we want and then the slug
or ID fair it's specific piece of
content and then that way we can just
keep reusing that one component of query
instead of making new components and
queries like we have been doing richard
says I'm new on programming and I'm here
that's why I read and try to understand
his code and uh yeah Richard you know
any questions that you have please let
me know be happy to help was trying to
understand you know sir if there's
something that you don't understand I
bet there are other people watching or
that are gonna watch the recording that
also you know could probably benefit
from an explanation and it always helps
me when I have to explain what I'm doing
sometimes I realize that something I've
done maybe I could do it better or you
know it's kind of illogical edits as
ionic framework no we're not using the
ionic framework right now just just
reacts Andy says react don't use
separation of concerns yeah it's not
it's definitely a shift in thinking you
know we don't separate everything out we
you know a component will have the mark
up the Jo
the scripts hmm I'm really sorry
let's keep yawning look one component
could have you know all the markup
JavaScript and styles that it would need
all in one file harsh ok let's get back
to let's get back to the code now harsh
it says have a spell to correct test for
faculty one time oh yeah that's true
maybe I didn't spell everything correct
about just make sure it's improv page
time now passing it about the age of age
the server
okay
I'm still I'm still kind of wondering
why why are we able to grab the ID value
here but not the type the only
difference I could see is that the ID is
in curly brackets right I don't know the
difference that would make
and still yeah no difference why this ID
are we L pose with rude with data
so
let me make sure the meat was somewhere
else just to make sure this is working
okay sort of make sure I didn't
accidentally mess up the WordPress
installation again Oh harsh it says that
he's got it all right cool our [ __ ] oops
there we go well use react clone element
page props type alright let's let's
share that out
okay
also want to change this back to what we
had
tej
okay-y so what's our render all right
let's see what we had cannot be property
edges so undefined okay alright well
that's just not bad
so the error basically this seems to be
working now which is good so now the
error is here in terms of the data that
we're getting back so I need to make
sure what we're passing in our [ __ ] says
try faculty
rsync try faculty like make a faculty
route and then try this on that actually
let me let me use graphic UL just to
make sure that this is working I don't
want to keep troubleshooting that if
that's not really a problem let's see
where's our page query
I can't find about in schema okay our
she's already checking the schema that's
a good idea
about page four about page yeah I
actually I see about page
hmm
let me check the router as well to see
if I'm not routing something ahead of
this
okay
alright that looks fine
suit I'm passing in
simple clear who is Purvis
let me che
- words faculty department as I was you
say no departments
okay so we are using this form right
associate programs that I just okay
into like this
I kind of want to see what's what we are
getting here let's see
oops let me double check the live chat
it looks like harsh it says about pages
the S the S
so should we use about pages
nah
so McCleary
no the quiz
Mageia query where majors
so she programs huh oh you know what I
need to restart the server sorry
can't just make a change and have it
work
let's see alright so yes and then now
here
okay and this is this is floral - yep
alright so everything does need to be
floral and it looks like we we have that
Nikki says it's taunting you flashing
the sight just before it gives you that
error page I know right hey come on
okay
I should say save the page so I guess I
have not saved it then
so that saves sent everything the server
save the server's well alright now I'll
restart
yes nothing
Ricki that's a good suggestion Ricky
says just console.log this props yet at
this point yeah it's like what am I
going to do
let me take this out so quick getting
errors
I could console.log in its console well
I want to make sure that I'm getting
tight in here properly too
mm-hmm cannot query field undefined all
right so it looks like type it is not
getting passed in properly let's see
all right so that does fix it
ah okay all right so at least we know
where the problem is now so everything
is coming in if as long as we can pass
about pages in it works so we know we
can get it from this props about pages
but we need so we need to be able to get
this props type here
I mean I honestly like this is just
gonna I don't know if this is the react
way but like just thinking like
JavaScript wise like this is just a
scope issue right like let type equal I
mean can we do something like this type
is this oh yeah I don't want to do query
type and then in here I can just say
clearly type equals type and then use
query type
No all right let's see expected name but
found cleavage
all right we have a different error now
which is progress in our queries okay so
we expected a name did not get the name
let's go let's console of type see what
we're getting yeah
and see
Harshit saying add yarn add recompose
actually yeah this is beside the point
we're obviously not getting the right
data in because we got it to work before
when we just hard-coded it so so what I
did must not have worked I don't know
why but it doesn't work so let's get rid
of what I just did then
all right we don't need this log anymore
all right great
all right so harsh is saying use
recompose I'll install it let's see
keep an eye on the time okay all right
so I have recomposed now I've never used
recompose I have no idea how to use
recompose I've just the Lance for a few
seconds at the documentation here
so I'm guessing I would use them at
props with Rican those
I heard a component map props or with
props okay with props
all right I'm checking out the API
documentation right now
[Music]
let's
this and here
Oh Michael Chris asking how to get to
the page that gives the heirs let me
just paste this is what I'm using so you
would replace localhost 3000 with the N
grukk URL obviously but that's that's
what I'm trying to test out all right
let's see
so now I'm gonna have a with props
creator of
all right so it's like mad so I'm
reading documentation for this on my
other screen so AHA that's I'm talking
to myself here okay
it looks like I can also use default
props
let's see if I can do
I need to find an example of this
because I'm not sure
alright let me bring over something I
found that somewhat similar to what
we're doing
seems like alright so right now they're
making higher-order components but and
here they're they're importing with
state from recompose which is similar to
the with props that we're trying to use
and let me give you here's the link to
the API documentation that I'm looking
at right now and it has the anchor
directly to the with prop section so
maybe if you all can can check it out
you know knowing what we're trying to do
with it you know can help me for some
reason I'm just missing something but
anyway so basically the export default
compose which is exactly what we're
doing but then here it says with States
and then we brought in the is visible
and toggle vis so and with handlers we
say toggle visibility and it looks like
there's now access to toggle vis and is
visible here so with that it seems like
what we should be able to do then is
when within with props we should be able
to just say type and then now we'll have
access to type as a variable
make sure put a comma there type is not
defined
okay the serum is let's see
now let's see maybe no it's still not
gonna do anything
alright let's check this out again
all right awesome okay so they're using
with props
so
let's check out with rob stuff looks
like we can grab it here let's just grab
that pull it over here with frost and
[Music]
all right so we're returning
all right Michael Chris is in that I
guess in the query are we starting off
with where don't you need to declare
what we're filtering on yes
let me see I can't see my chat my chat
window is now zoomed in and won't let me
zoom out and I can't see anything okay
now why is it doing this
there we are finally okay page create
shouldn't be page where yet the query is
fine so there's the where we have so
we're pulling in the type so that should
be should be okay
nice let's go back to here and just say
so this is
all right
yeah
it's okay
all right I don't only think this will
work let's give it a shot type no still
nothing
this prob site no it shouldn't
I say this props is undefined
okay fifty props in fine
yep okay
okay
all right harsh it says now Final
Solution
update Apollo there is a new query
component no need of composing then
alright let's take this out then
so let's check out this new component
that we can use
whoops github.com holographic it's not
working releases that was for your new
query component
what
Wow
okay I'll shout out there
we'll check our package.json to make
sure we get the version we want so this
should be 2 12.1
no didn't get that all right
all right we taken out recompose and
let's make sure we take this out of our
component and we may not get this
working in time we'll see rican folks
into
oops
all right so let's try to get this oops
hey Otis let's try to get this beta
version running so let's see if this
works so this is Harshit suggestion see
we had to follow later sir
okay I see your other suggestion there
horseshit
yeah and that is what we need right beta
2.1 2.1 awesome okay let's just make
sure you break everything okay cool
still works alright so now I guess we
can use stuff like this and for poor
query I listen for these
[Music]
so can we just get rid of both of those
then and then down here
do we need any of this now we still need
compose all right
sunbaes says Jesse you are alien as far
as I know I am NOT but maybe maybe you
know something that I don't
alright alright let's go back to our
example here
so let's take this oops let me see if I
can feel it
all right let's Swift query and now we
need to grab what our query was
[Music]
okay
okay and we should be able to do her
name equals strength
and how are we reassigning okay so we're
saying variables name ID so we should be
able to
we should be able to add in
is props tight and now that's what I'm
confused about
that sorry heart is saying leave the
query
I'm not exactly sure where he was
talking about to leave the query anyway
what I'm not sure about is we're past
when we're passing this name in our says
remove the query stuff so all this query
stuff
michael says I'm so lost so I'm going to
need I'm gonna read up on so I
understand what's going on I'm pretty
lost myself here as well so I guess just
to catch everybody up to speed including
myself just as a review we've updated to
the beta version the 2.1 beta version of
react apollo there's a different way to
do queries a query component I'm trying
to convert over to using this query
component but I'm not sure about it as
China follow Harshit and I get the
messages removed graph Kiel from export
so I did that no need of query and then
the next message was leave the query and
then the next message was remove query
stuff so I'm not exactly sure what
what's going on because I've gotten both
leave the query and remove the query I'm
gonna drink some lead you
[Music]
all right harsh it says you have Adam
still let me edit the code using tell us
a but started to explain in the chat
yeah I do have Adam alright let me check
the time see if we have time for this
I really do want to use tell the site
because it sounds really cool but I
think I'm gonna have to end the stream
because I need to I need to make sure I
get everything ended in enough time for
me to get ready and pick up my kids from
school so what if beautifully wrap
things up here I commit what I have and
then work on it tomorrow
does that sound good
so I kind of figured on the street being
over by now all right I'm just I'm gonna
scroll through really quickly just to
make sure there hasn't been a question
that I missed
Ravi Raj says are you an independent
developer or work for free code camp I
volunteer for free code camp and I work
for a university so I'm a front-end
developer for a small university I also
do some work on the side I like
freelancing work
Droon s when I use Visual Studio code on
Windows the font isn't that bold how can
I make it look like that I'm not sure
I'm using the seti theme to seti I don't
think I've done anything else besides
just use a different theme I mean I've
made the font bigger but other than that
I don't maybe it's just the theme igor
says where can I find your custom post
types post plug-in I don't know if I
have it I don't know if I have it
available and get up or not check out
the CI react repo so it'll be in the
same organization as this repo it might
be in there it might be listed as like
CI custom post types or catechol
Institute custom post types it's
basically the same plug-in I'll just add
some some different sites but maybe it
might not be a bad idea to add that in
with this repo as well
Michael here is asking about a react
tutorial code Academy has a pretty easy
intro react tutorial
Michael crow says is there any way to
see your data structure not sure our
WordPress works I don't know I guess I
mean normally if I'm running WordPress I
usually have it running on something
that has like PHP myadmin
and I can look at it but I don't have
that right now so I I don't know I mean
it's following the same structure as a
normal WordPress so maybe there's like
an example online of the normal data
structure for WordPress all right so
yeah let me commit this let's see what
the status is I could say some pages you
unlock okay what do I need a feature
page
don't think so
shoot I figured that'd be the case
queries the fun but never use gql was
too fine to get rid of that and then I'm
pretty sure he's queer you didn't I'll
save it
what
fifty-four maybe I should just take this
stuff out
yes take that out let's take a page
query and query and a graph QL oh there
we are Harsha says just use no verify
yeah that would have made sense I should
have done that all right let's just run
a how did my server die jsq modified
yep that's what I meant
come on no there if you yes
here we are all right okay
all right everything is now committed
and we will pick this up again tomorrow
so I've already gone through all the
questions in the live chat and my brain
is tired right now so learning something
new it's hard enough but it's I I guess
learning something new on the live
stream is harder all right so I'll see
you all tomorrow like I have an early
meeting tomorrow I'm gonna try to get in
early enough to schedule the stream
before my meeting and then that way I
can jump right into it if I don't get in
that early though I might not be I'll
try to distrain at the same time but it
might not actually be scheduled so you
may not be getting a notification on
YouTube you know like an early
notification or any at all so I'll see
I'm gonna try my best to get in and and
get this scheduled all right thanks for
all the help
almost had it Lee almost said it today I
think we're really close I mean
basically everything's working except
just need to pass that that's typed
through to the query so we knew it
already works when we manually pass it
through so I mean I'm happy with that
the concept works so from here on out
it'll definitely cut down on the amount
of work we have to do and it'll clean
things up so I guess I guess we did
enough to prove that the concepts works
so we could let's count that as a win
right all right thanks for watching and
I'll be back tomorrow until then have a
great day